[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours aimé benjamin vous voulez
mais depuis qu'il est dans l'émission
depuis très longtemps depuis très
longtemps et vous l'avez encore plus
aimer quantité de rémission ou moins
bien j'étais super content qu'il arrive
nous fait c'est vrai et ben superbe et
ça nous fait plaisir
cet amour avec question pour valérie
venez vous avez presque déjà répondu
tout à l'heure c'est quoi dites moi la
première fois vous avez rencontré cyril
oui est ce qu'il a essayé de vous draghi
ou pas la première fois qu'il est
question
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
cyril n'a jamais essayé de me draguer il
a tout de suite été sur le registre du
copain du copain complètement fou
furieux ses brûlures non non j'ai
souvenir de lui dans une fin dans une
radio il y avait des déchets passé le
premier souvenir qui me vient vraiment
on se connaissait à peine y avait des bd
je sais plus fins des apéritifs des
machins il s'est mis à je connaissais
pas ce garçon il a pris le bol comme ça
de trucs il s'est mis à danser avec en
les jetant dans tous les sens ah oui je
me suis jetée moi c'était ce type il
s'est mis à danser autour de moi en me
disant salut toi ça va et je me suis là
je vais kent mais il n'a jamais cherché
à me draguer du tout cela dit ouais cela
dit ouais j'ai appris en faisant une
émission de radio avec lui qu il avait
eu un petit penchant pour moi alors je
sais pas s'il a dit ça pour rigoler ou
pour plaisanter mais il avait dit d'une
façon un peu sérieuse qui m'a un peu
troublé je ne le cache pas quand on sait
qu'à cette époque là effectivement que
j'étais à tf1 il avait eu un petit
penchant pour moi et mais il ne l'avait
jamais dit et je ne mettais absolument
pas venu à l'esprit
j'aurais pu dire oui site était
célibataire pardon aurait pu dire oui si
tu avais été cédée matin à l'époque
west ham est fin et j'aurais peut-être
oui succombé au charme de série parce
qu'il est il est très drôle
[Applaudissements]
alors on est venus s'amuser mais naïve
on est venu prendre du bon temps la
belle marocaine un centre est bon oui je
sais très froid aussi j'aurais dit oui
j'aurais dit oui ou aqua basse appareil
si vous voulez gagner célibataire si
j'aurais dit oui comme benamara non pas
avec ça